50 Gucchima Veil hiroki sakai Quoi qu'il en soit, je suis japonais.
Donc, après tout, ça commence par moins, eh bien, c'est pareil dans tous les pays.
mais
Évaluation évaluation pour les japonais
Après tout, une telle place est encore faible et la première saison est un bon jeu
Même si c'est encore, voyons-le.
Ce genre de
Ce n'était pas un voyage facile
Si vous pouvez évaluer la femme de ménage petit à petit comme ça et obtenir la position debout actuelle
Ce que j'ai fait est
Je pense que ce n'était pas une erreur
Très pour le temps
Le Japon est-il vraiment lâche ?
Est-ce exact ?
Vraiment à l'étranger
Plus tu avances, plus tu vois le train
La différence de précision et de précision de livraison est vraiment
Je pense que c'est de loin le meilleur
Ou quelque chose comme ça
Se sentir stressé
Je pense que c'est stressant, donc je vais attendre
Je pense surtout ici quand je suis un représentant
Après tout c'est une action 5 minutes avant le joueur
Il y a 5 minutes, il y a toujours un rassemblement au lieu de réunion
La situation où il y a des joueurs qui flirtent il y a environ 10 minutes
Mais quand je pars il y a 5 minutes, je suis le premier
Alors petit à petit l'école
je m'adapte
Je suis toujours anxieux comme ça. Il y a cinq minutes, j'ai commencé à avoir les jambes doubles.
Au contraire, c'est un bon endroit parce que c'est lâche.
La marge de temps est
Il y a tellement de gens, après tout ce sont des humains
je me suis levé un peu tard
Il y a des endroits où je suis un peu en retard pour l'heure du rendez-vous, mais je suis totalement inquiet
Parce qu'il n'y a pas ça
Les gens de ce pays sont comme ça
C'est une erreur commise par une personne ou une erreur accidentelle.
Mais réellement
Je pense que c'est un pays généreux
Avec autre chose que
Je ne sais pas si c'est dans le sud, mais c'est étonnamment international.
On dit que c'est discriminatoire, mais ce n'est pas si doux.
Parce qu'il y a pas mal de races différentes mélangées comme ça
Il est donc normal que les Asiatiques marchent, même s'ils marchent
Au contraire, au Japon, il semble que les étrangers se retournent en marchant.
et
Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de discrimination.
Il y avait des moments où je pensais que c'était proche de la sensation de distance.
Je pense que je m'y habitue
Je pensais que c'étaient de bonnes personnes, mais au début j'étais surpris.
Parce que c'est une ville de football
C'était spécial, peu importe ce que tu as fait
Le résultat était bon car il est directement lié au football. Si la rediffusion est bonne
La réaction des citadins est vraiment à 180 degrés, et au contraire, si c'est mauvais, tout me reviendra.
Bon après tout c'est un pays ou une équipe
Les personnes qui appartiennent à cette personne
Personnel
Tout le monde doit d'abord respecter
Est-il possible de créer une relation ?
Ce gamin ne vient pas, et ça me fait vraiment du bien.
Et les footballeurs, après tout
La tension était très élevée hier, mais le lendemain, la tension est déjà tombée.
Parce que c'est un métier
je suis vraiment jeune
Une expérience qui vous rend vraiment inquiet et fatigué
Si vous en faites vraiment l'expérience dès votre plus jeune âge
Quand je suis devenu adulte, quand j'ai acquis de l'expérience, j'ai déjà revécu la même situation
Parce que c'est une chose, il est possible de la surmonter.
Parce que vous pouvez faire quelque chose comme
Surtout ici, 18 c'est vraiment fort
Le lendemain de ma défaite, je suis tellement déprimé que je n'ai vraiment plus envie de sortir.
De plus, je dis fermement que je n'ai pas d'autre choix que d'obtenir des résultats sur un terrain que je n'ai d'autre choix que de regarder en arrière dans le football.
Le travail de le nettoyer au milieu et de se diriger à nouveau vers le prochain match
Je l'ai déjà expérimenté depuis 26 car je peux le faire, mais je l'ai fait avec 2220 Atouch
Si vous rencontrez
Je pense que je vais vivre sur une plus grande scène
Eh bien, c'est vraiment chaud dans le football et c'est vraiment chaud.
je veux dire il y en a beaucoup
C'est enviable, n'est-ce pas ?En tant qu'habitant d'un quartier, si le Japon devient comme ça.
C'est un pays où tout le monde parle de foot le lendemain.
Eh bien, l'Allemagne aussi
Je me demande si ça va ressembler à ça, je pense que ça va devenir encore plus excitant.
Mon rêve est devenu réalité. Eh bien, cette fois
Combien
Je me demande si ça va continuer, mais chaque match est vraiment bien
Je pense que je dois obtenir des résultats
Je dois le faire avec un sentiment si fort
Sinon, je suis vraiment le Japon
Je dois penser à l'option de rentrer à la maison.
Je ne pense pas que ce soit comme s'accrocher à ce chat, mais celui-ci
Je viens jouer un rôle actif
Si vous ne pouvez pas jouer un rôle actif, vous rentrerez chez vous
je dois passer ou avoir une netteté
je pense que je ne peux pas le faire
faire de son mieux
Ana